good morning Millennials it's morning
everyone it's been so long since we said
that
happy Monday welcome back from just a
beautiful July 4th extended weekend I
know I'm sick July 4th being on
Wednesday is the greatest thing that
ever happened this is the longest
holiday ever and like by the time I was
over I was ready for it to go next year
when it's on a Thursday that'll be
perfect and like the country was really
torn because some people took off the
Saturday and Sunday preceding and Monday
Tuesday so half people were working half
people weren't I'm really excited for
next year and we're all on the same page
let's do something really fun you guys
totally and it'll be crazy but I really
I did enjoy my very long week yeah it
felt like a real vacation it did by the
time I was coming home I was ready to
come home like that's how you know like
the vacation land lasted long enough
yeah because when you have a weekend
trip actually I'm always ready to come
home
also I survived yes my secretly if I was
it it was not bad so I asked the points
guy I was like why do you prefer he said
eh it's safer because if anything
happens you fall in water they're only
allowed to fly over water ok and to the
take-off is a lot like smoother than
that of a helicopter and the takeoff was
fine I mean it was just odd to me like
in a boat and then like in air do you
know what I mean yeah because you like
shoot across the water and then
eventually lift off and the plane ride
was was bumpy at points and when it was
bumpy it was [ __ ] scary but my only
real complaint was that it was hot as
hell on the plane that's so scary I
don't think I'll ever take a helicopter
in my life
III think I'm set no any more whatever
they say like single-engine planes you
got to get a double engine because you
get one engine fails then you're slowly
Sully as hell
Sully should get a seaplane because he's
obsessed with landing on the teeth do
you think in the movie Sully they made
it seem like he had like a fetish with
the Hudson River not a fetish but like
no I know you knew it was like he was
happy that this happened to him that was
a weird movie yeah he was like and like
even though there was so much drama like
he still was like glad it happened no it
was like in the movie starts and he's
like running along the Hudson he the
Hudson they're taking off he and he says
to his co-pilot sure looks beautiful
today
but like I get one fit I get what Clint
is a beautiful place her tumors Andy
I can't what Clint Eastwood was trying
to do I think he was just wanting to
make the Hudson like a focal point but
instead he made it seem like Tom Hanks
was in love with the Hudson and like was
kind of hoping to one day land yes in
exactly but he should now be a pilot for
blade and only 5c puddings hold actually
he should start his own seaplane company
called Sulley done actually
sign me up I would not fly it's not a
great advertisement also what do you do
first I went to carry under wind and
Shake concert at Pier 17 and it was lit
and so toasty I miss our house I met so
many toaster families now seem down into
8 twice and I haven't seen twice in one
week and I haven't seen the months and I
almost went to Jones Beach even though
that plan felt I was sick very quickly
felt throw but like on Friday I was like
chillin and I'm like well I really wish
I was that Jones Beach um
they were so good they are so good and
Carrie Underwood and her new face were
there and she she was great per usual um
I didn't do anything
actually OSL fireworks on the beach in
Montauk which was amazing and the beat
the Montauk Beach which is where like
the big thing was it was only like ten
miles from our house it took us three
hours to get back three hours I spent a
nice piece so bad she'd have baked
I should have literally done anything
else that's horrible horrible and like
we were in the convertible and like it
was amazing but when we weren't moving
I'm like I'm sitting outside I'm gonna
close the [ __ ] thing like they lost
its novelty so quickly you know Wow I
gotta get in a convertible and then
what'd you do Thursday what did I do
Thursday I think I went to the spa does
that make sense
I'm trying to remember trying to repaint
my me too it was all one it was all a
dream um Thursday I just hung out
yeah I Thursday just hang out I think I
went to so house for for dinner oh man
so house was so quiet really oh nice and
like twinkly and beautiful and the Sun
was setting and people weren't there and
it was so amazing and the weather was
perfect wasn't really cold at night um
yeah the weather like in the Hamptons
was only like 75 but the Sun was so
strong that it felt hard today was fine
but at night it was a nice breeze I got
a bit chilly what else happened oh I
okay so I went to surf Lodge which is
like literally the only place I might
talk to hang out I went there every
single night one of the nights
someone was like there's an actor here
Liam and I was like
and they look into student black Adam
let's leave Schreiber and like I told
everyone that Liev Schreiber was that
Montauk I mean was that survived like
and it's like for everyone else that
would be that was young people were like
running around looking for him
and then Ben Stein the victim was like
glutted that's not Liev Schreiber it's
Liam no no sorry it's not wait you told
people as Liam Neeson yeah but it was
Liev Schreiber Oh which was people were
less excited but still something to me
they are the same person I was trying to
come up with one difference and the only
difference I could come up was the two
different letters in their name maybe
Emily Emily if they're both white
straight actors who get all the action
roles the only difference is that Liev
Schreiber isn't from taken right so I
thought he was
whatever iam Neeson is taken and that's
like the two are one in the same it was
kind of weird that he was there like
it's such like a like a scene II place
like people yeah celebrities don't go
there like not to be seen like so as a
place like that so like people were just
like broke gonna buy you a beer and he
was close I guess yeah Wow
I mean it who I would do the same yeah
and then Friday was Shabbat lovely
lovely
I'm trying to like a recount everything
Thursday just fell into a dark hole for
me I know it's a Corinne and I saw food
gone on Saturday night right which was
awesome I only have positive things to
say about the both of them there were
some mean comments on my Instagram which
I was confused about because like about
which one both and I'm like they're both
he literally universally well-liked like
who does not like them uh there everyone
has haters yeah that's true but like I
was just confused because I thought it
was a great picture my neck looks
amazing it was it was a cute picture and
it's like oh like you guys are a good
squad yeah my neck like really how are
you doing with your neck like I felt it
cuz this is the first time where it's
like I've been I always get super hot
when I go out especially in the summer
I'm like I didn't feel like embarrassed
to put my hair up where as I usually did
cuz like it really opened up my neck and
I had this moment it's like I just felt
like free do you know I'm gonna go for a
nap do soon no no no but like when it's
hot and you put your hair up like I was
cool with it you know and I felt like
good about it that's exciting that was
exciting and also didn't help that it
wasn't like that hot this weekend you
know mm-hmm oh I got into lipo on
Thursday oh I had my fourth session I
have two more sessions before you like
working I'm not sure like I definitely
feel like I'm getting smaller like an B
so I take a picture of my outfit every
day which you would think is vain but
it's actually great for weight loss
purposes because I was looking at my
daily cry insta highlight and you can
really see my weight fluctuation like so
nicely oh and so I feel like I'm getting
smaller but I also feel like it's making
my arms look bigger and like my
shoulders look broader but I'm excited
to get my measurements because I have no
broken clue what I look like which is
evidenced by the fact that I finally
weighed myself on Wednesday
not since Claudia's wedding and you guys
I'm so sorry I've been out of control
and I'm on a very serious diet I weighed
myself like two weeks no like oh wait
two weeks ago for like the first time in
like years well it was the last time
like I have no idea like the doctor's
office no and I usually tell them not to
tell me and you know I've always said
like if I hit this certain number like
I'll kill myself you know and I hit it
but I'm still here so that sucks I said
when I said on the scale I was like if I
hit this certain number like I'll get
myself yeah I was pointing for whatever
man Wow God loves you truly yeah also
revealed a was was Wednesday that's like
my whole life was a blur because I was
addicted to my phone like I was with
Ben's whole family and like I just
couldn't be bothered to sit down for
lunch or do anything because I was like
on the hammock literally refreshing
every 15 minutes
I'm putting premium content on our
Instagram page we are going to do a
whole patreon episode about us because
if we did on the show would take up way
too much time so we have a very special
guest today Alexis waters we have so
much premium content in the news today
so we are recording patreon after this
all the blinds revealed all of our
thoughts
subscribe to our patreon patrons fashion
wearing toast where you also get access
to our award-winning film we made a film
last week and it was like a big hit it
was a big hit it took us forever but it
was worth it it's I really think there's
Oscar buzz surrounding AJ Lee's Tribeca
Film Festival that's all I'm saying
maybe a little Sundance it can get la la
Kent is a minute can film possible maybe
perhaps maybe are we continental no not
at all international international cuz
Walden we're international cosmopolitan
also if you become a pH remember you're
gonna get presale access to my Boston
show so I've been like really annoying
teasing but I'm not being like I just
have live Airy limited information but
now I have all the info ready at noon
today presale begins for patreon members
so if you're not a pH remember you just
want to become one for a month just to
get tickets is eight dollars I think
it's worth it go to patreon.com/scishow
money toast then on a Friday it gets
open to the public so PHR members are
gonna have four
days to buy tickets before you so I'm
really excited about it I don't know if
I told you guys I'd like this is a big
deal and just tell my ticket for
yourself buy one for your mom for your
dad for your sister for your aunt like
what is it the show was in October so
planned you have enough time to plan ok
what day of the week it's a Thursday
night like it's a little well that's
actually good for me notice I'm leaving
town that weekend you are
I'll leave from Boston yeah I have a
wedding in every wedding I think you
have to come yet but I'll go to Boston
then I'll and then I'll leave town
no they'd never say that but you have to
I was already planning Oh coming I need
to meet the boss Dean see that yeah and
I was plating I'm like maybe getting a
party bus to take us there something
like I'm gonna make it it's my last show
of the tour it'll be a celebration and
it's my biggest one and it's like a big
deal the theater it's at the Wilbur
theater which is like I think the
equivalent of the Beacon Theater here in
New York like prestige wise prestige
worldwide so it's just gonna be so great
I'm really excited
we've more Hannah for a while and I just
I love everyone that's all I have to say
and my birthday's tomorrow and like I
don't want to talk about it seriously
well you're okay I just want to say this
is you my birthday Samar I don't want to
do anything maybe a small dinner at home
I don't want to talk about it this is
you my birthday weeks kicking off on the
toast tomorrow I know I know you know
what I was writing that caption Tuesday
Pardoner's day better be there Oh some
of us I know mean I know honestly like
it's all just a facade for social media
okay like I'm not gonna admit that like
in real life like I really don't care
and like I honestly like I love being
the center of attention except on my
birthday I can't explain that because I
know it's like fake people only doing it
because it's my birthday
you know what I mean I guess so let's
just embrace it because once it's over
it's a whole year until your next one
how old are you turning I don't want to
talk about it because I thought up until
yesterday in the car ride home that I
was turning 23 because when I turned 23
I was like now I'm 22 still so this
whole time I really thought I was
turning 23 but it turns out I'm 24
you know what and that's a tough pill to
swallow but at least that you'll always
be the youngest person on the show
that's true you know there's no way that
you'll ever be older than me Wow thank
you for prospective
you're what helps yeah because you know
you're the young one yeah like I'm 25
also I'm getting a bunch of questions
people want to know why me and Corrine
were crying because been put up on his
boy with no job Instagram story like a
picture being cringe is like standing
and honey
each other and crying I'm like well when
I got there like I was pretty like drunk
but Corinne was like super drunk and she
was just like so excited to see me she
like started crying about how much he
loves me and they're like when she
started crying I was like I have to cry
too and she's just being like so cute
and sweet and like she really is like
the nicest girl ever and just like she
weighs like 90 pounds she's just so
small you know the smallest face she's
just tiny like in actually I have a
small space now but she's just so small
and frail in like every regard and she
was just being so cute and sweet and I
just love her I need she's crying you're
a new small face next to Margo's yeah
because mine's probably smaller Margo's
face is so small but Corrine has the
smallest face like another on another
level yeah okay love Yoko patreon
patreon today tickets noon patreon fast
five stories you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast you guys I feel so good
about these stories today and it's been
so long since I've been able to say that
and we have like internally we had a
creative strategy meeting yeah we had
great story braids no session we it was
like basically just one conversation and
an uber but we basically said like we've
been talking about the same [ __ ] on
repeat
since we started the toast like
literally we were talking about Tristan
Thompson like the day we started the
toast and we still are talking about it
and I'm just like I want to broaden my
horizons like I want wider interests
like I want more things to be funny on
like I can no longer just be funny about
Ariana and Pete because there's
literally nothing funny about it there's
nothing scary no but we still will not
be talking about like world news or
politics
no but just more tech more science just
like I don't know different stories yeah
but I'm still interested in like this
environmental story we have today I mean
it sounds so warning it's not gonna be
boring it's not gonna be boring it's
gonna be pertinent to the situation as
it always is without further ado here
the past five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast but not me
because I'm on Atkins for the rest of
the time okay first up Haley Baldwin
Justin Bieber are engaged which is wild
and I have so many thoughts about on it
but first I'm gonna give you the facts
Justin Bieber appears to have spared no
expense for Haley Baldwin's engagement
ring reports TMZ because that ring is
huge the newly engaged couple were seen
hanging out at nippers Bar and Grill in
the Bahamas the day after he proposed to
her Saturday night and she was flashing
her new hardware oh my god I went to
that bar once mhm
and I got the worst drunk injury of my
life I was leaning I was on um a
barstool but I was like leaning on my
shins and like so barstool was on one
leg oh my god and of course it came out
for my worst and I fell on top of the
legs of the barstool but my shins broke
the fall and my whole shins were black
and blue and swollen and like so big
like I had right chunkier legs cause of
my bruises but compared to the Tipsy
toasters have you seen some of those
dresses charting that group was
literally the best thing I ever did
because like it makes men I was going
through it like makes you want to go out
and party it's like girls stay safe out
there like yeah girl who had the biggest
bruise think you see that one oh my god
okay basically the tipsy toasters is a
subgroup of our morning toasters
Facebook group and it's just for people
who like want to talk about like being
drunk and like favorite cocktail recipes
and like just favorite drunk memory so
people share like videos of like them
falling and pictures of like what and
this girl put up a picture of her what's
her thigh Roshan I think he's like a
little lost her whole leg but it was her
leg was just purple like it was the
biggest bruise I ever saw my life and it
was like purple red it was like yellow
on the outskirts oh my god it was
horrible
anyways that was my experience at this
bar so I'm glad they've had a better
experience yes
Hayley's wearing a fat diamond ring on
that finger and the open her ring is
really pretty using it it's a very large
oval stone and we got to say it looks
like the hell of a rock hard to say
exactly how big it is but there's no
question the ring is sizable didn't they
dance their hearts out on the beach and
celebration so cute so it seems she dig
it she digs it
so wait just quickly the best part about
this entire story is that TMZ wrote it
up at like noon but at 9:00 a.m. someone
in the toasters group was on it's like a
private island in the Bahamas and she's
like a member of that Club and she was
there and she was like you guys I swear
to god Haley Baldwin and Justin Bieber
engage I just saw her she's wearing a
wedding ring
and so it broke in on our thing like
three hours ago and then like we were
with Ben's family and Ben's sister was
like alabanza Cajun like yeah yeah when
I saw it on the toast Instagram I was
like how did I already know that right
because the toasters are the best litter
everybody wants to be a part of it and
they can't be no they can't unless your
toaster um also I have like I don't know
I'm really torn mm-hmm because I see
what I see like in the press but then I
also read the blinds
um and I really want to believe that
like this was an Haley Baldwin really
was the first girl that Justin Beiber
like ever like settle down and dated and
I thought they were really cute in a
moment and now he's like spiraling like
she's kind of spiraling too but like the
whole Shawn Mendes thing like I don't
know I really truly want to believe that
this is genuine but like I'm feeling it
song okay
here's my thoughts on it I thought long
and hard about it and I think it would
be really easy to like write this off as
a PETA nari on the situation like you
know they're crazy kids these crazy kids
like this is way too soon bla bla bla
but I choose to be naive men look on the
bright side and just try and try and
believe it right this is how I've
rationalized it because I don't want to
like read the blinds and know that this
is faking but what the blind everything
is really sad is that Haley Baldwin
always goes back to Justin Bieber when
she needs money yes that's what he says
so and ndo is right but I'm gonna give
you an alternative mhm
they have dated a lot they know each
other very well it's not a pedan Ariana
situation they probably have dated
communally for like years no I don't
think that this is a competing or like
Ariana rushing into it they great I
don't think so and you know what like
they really I have always been good
friends even when they weren't dating
they have both a very strong
relationship with the church and they're
bowling very religious in that sense
yeah Hillsong and I think they kind of
like brought them back together and I'm
just gonna choose to believe like this
is a young Christian couple who just
want to get married young okay and IOC
are doing it in the eyes of the church I
totally see it I totally forgot about
the church first of all second of all
what people was no no you know what I'm
loving it's like I feel like in the 70s
like this trend of like celebrities like
getting together getting married like
they would like get married they would
even get married they were just like
stay together and like overdose like I
love that our generation like a crazy
thing they're doing is like getting
married it's so nice I love that that
they're setting this president like
Justin Bieber is like The Bachelor of
America yeah that's her and like he's
setting the precedent like when you love
a girl propose like and the Pete and
Ariana thing even though people are like
it's crazy like he's crazy like people
say mean things about them
Oh like they're just in love I think and
like if the craziest thing they're doing
is being monogamous that's wonderful
yeah and I think it's a great example to
be sending it to their of their of their
appropriate ages for each other
and I think like what I've learned from
Auntie it's like no one grows up in this
business unscathed they they definitely
have a mutual hardness hardness and like
they definitely both seen and been
through a lot so I'm going to choose
this reconciliation this coming together
as a nice thing for the both of them
until Angie comes in ruins it for you
right of course and and I'll always have
that in the back of my mind but you know
sometimes it's nice to live in a fantasy
show if I just know that everything is a
bad Constitution yeah and oh well
molestation totally and you know what
ignorance truly is bliss I totally agree
blissfully ignorant like under that
phrase do you know I mean yeah and she
made me realize it yeah like if I mean
ignorant these two are like sun-soaked
babes yeah with a big ring on her finger
age-appropriate drinking alcohol ienzo
bridge and thinks his own music de Soto
on the beach having time of their lives
and you know what that's something I can
get behind
yeah no I'm just like I'm just loving
this trend of like monogamy I think it's
crappy I think it's great too even
though we don't know for sure that he
like doesn't cheat on her no for sure
but but like proposing and like like
it's just it's a good example to set I
agree and if he wants to sleuth around
on his own free time he's still setting
a good example
yeah I just don't let other people know
about to say things like yeah at that
example but anyways I'm officially here
for it and I'm especially happy
I kind of agree and and I actually love
Haley Baldwin even though she did
comment on her Instagram a while ago and
something not so nice but we caught we
started it we started it for sure we
shaded her and by the way I disagreed
with the shade because I said basically
when we did the be the morning be one of
our news stories was that when Haley
Baldwin got named Maxim's number one of
their hot 100 list and I was like yes
like finally she really is like just
universally beautiful she's not like
interesting she's just beautiful like
she's a very pretty girl look and that's
why she doesn't model for like Chanel
she's not different looking she's just
beautiful smell of food yes doesn't
model fur like high fashion because
she's not that tall and because she's
really just like American babe she's
what Gigi looked like when she was on
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills doing
the guest campaigns and did that
Australian bikini line sort of she's
really skinny though yes but um yes no
I'm just saying like face wise like Gigi
American Girl look there's nothing like
Gigi with commercial she's not sure
exactly exactly
when Gigi was on like Sports Illustrated
and like she was like busty and
library's rookie she looked like a young
Kate Upton like that was so epic but
really she lost a lot of weight and like
her face really did change and now she's
much more editorial looking yes
Haley Baldwin but actually the high
thing like she's just a America's
Sweetheart looking like she's just a
speckle blue-eyed blonde-haired beauty
so when we said Jackie wrote the caption
on Instagram I was like are we here for
Haley Baldwin I think yeah and I just
agree but Haley bubblin was like well
it's a good thing it's not your choice
and like who wants to die I do want to
say I stand by that she that was a
little like you don't get to be maximum
number one on the Hot 100 when you're
up-and-coming like you're number one
whether they're and I feel like this
year she is there yes and I didn't feel
that way last year and I'm happy for her
clearly she's doing all right oh my god
speaking of Haley Baldwin the speeches
this year oh hi smooches smooches
speaking of Ellie woman I forgot one
part my weekend that I wanted to share
because it's epic I was this our collage
obviously and they haven't uh look it's
a day party that goes in tonight and
there's one hour where they have a
performer and Justine Skye performed and
I remember meeting Justine Skye at a
Fashion Week event i sat right behind
her and all I could think was that this
was the prettiest girl I'd ever seen in
my whole life like she had straight hair
like down to her ass and every
photographer was taking a picture permit
in the background of all them and I was
just thinking like who is this girl
she's stunning then I found out it was
Justin Skye Kylie's friend you know then
she's been this was like two years ago
now she's like an up-and-coming singer
and she perform at surf Lodge first of
all she was just epic like she had the
most I didn't know any of the songs
which like I hate listening to music I
don't know yeah but she had such great
energy on stage and her voice is amazing
and I did an Instagram story like I have
[ __ ] loved Justine Skye and she
shared it on her story oh my god and
then I see I'm sure I was like oh my god
I love you so much and she was like your
epic thanks and I was like sorry just
once showed a little bit of my weekend
that's very very very happy for the two
of them and I wish great success who
just seems okay good
that's a nice bow to tie this story up
on yeah we'll keep you updated you know
as they break up but for right now very
happy for the
happy table next story is really shaking
the world to the core Kylie Jenner
reveals she quote got rid of her famous
lip it just really cool a photo I love
how we're like we're gonna talk about
different stuff and our first two
sororities write very similar but the
next three aren't to the next two are
yes she got rid of all of her fillers
and I love him like my favorite part
about being a millennial is that
Instagram comments are now news stories
right so Cara Lee put up a picture with
Stas her blonde friend and she looked
like old Kylie and someone was like wow
Kylie you look so different she's like I
got rid of all my fillers so I guess
that's uh not only her lips that's her
like cheekbones - I think she just meant
her lips cuz the rest of her kind of
looks the same but I don't know I know
so how do you get rid of fillers don't
they just fizzle out I don't know I was
thinking this like you out check to them
right unless she had like a like an
implant I don't think she did that maybe
there's just been enough time she
probably hasn't gotten them like since
she got pregnant and now they're really
gone yeah so and she chopped her hair
she did she's looking so naturally and I
am here for it I think she looks amazing
I love Kylie no matter what I support
her no matter what I thought she looked
amazing with the fillers and I loved
that she was just like open about I just
want to say everyone think she looks
amazing now and she does and she's a
beautiful girl but like I thought she
looked good before - no Same Same Same
Same Same Same to him and i really feel
like she needed the fillers for her
brand and now that the brand is just
like a billion dollar business
self-sustained on its own generating
revenue on every turn she doesn't need
that anymore like she can go back to
being herself it's almost like this was
like a costume yeah also it's a great
like message to send is that you know
you're beautiful just the way you are
yeah and if you have money and if you
choose not to get fillers anymore
totally but also like if you're insecure
about something like and you want to fix
it that's also okay right so she's doing
both sides of it she's like I know what
I was really insecure about it and I had
the means and I fix it and I felt a lot
better about myself but now I'm grown up
and I feel differently and like I don't
know I just think like I in a weird way
she's a good role model no I totally
agree cuz both are good messages yes
totally and she's the proof is in the
pudding she's practicing what she
preaches did you watch her bug makeup
thing I watch it I'm in love with it
she is the funniest person in the whole
world I have to say that that bugged
makeup thing like I think everything
vogue does is like so lame and they're
like
the times unlike every regard like seven
three questions is the lamest thing ever
and it's so fake and it's scripted
because you could tell everyone like
remembers their answer yeah and it's
like a one-shot yep and it's like not
real and you don't even get to see the
outside of the person's house which is
like the most important part but this
makeup thing that they did was
everything I love it okay I agree with
you cuz Rihanna and Kylie were so good
and I watched how I was like wow this is
incredible I want to get this
perspective on other people
I watched Haley Baldwin's boring I
watched Rosie huntington-whiteley
she started with no makeup and she left
with no makeup if I showed you the way
that she did her concealer
she took her thing she put one dot here
and one dot there and it's how she does
her consider I'm sorry I just can't I
used to see those makeup things on
YouTube and they did it with like a
bunch of models like I saw sawdust on
pillows and I'm like she doesn't even
need makeup so I was completely
uninterested in it but now that they're
having people like Kylie and Rihanna who
wear real makeup and did both have
makeup lines and are like really
educated about it the video scent
becomes so much more premium but I
couldn't read more they started off like
doing models makeup and like I said one
time I watched jazz Jasmine chooks jae
suk's do her makeup and it was
unbelievable she's so good at it even
though she doesn't need it she did such
a good job and like she was using
eyeshadow for powder like it was really
interesting but moving the most part
like I don't need to see him outer wear
makeup all they do is wear mascara and
blush and like that's not realistic
glass
yeah that's not helpful and they're
getting better with the talent that
they're choosing and it's become because
it's bigger stars and more interesting
people yeah but like who else would you
want to hear from I just feel like
Rihanna and Kylie are just the two most
interesting people on the planet yeah
like I could I could stand for Kim to do
one and then okay you know what like I I
wouldn't have thought that I wouldn't
have needed a video like that from
Rihanna but it was the best thing I ever
saw in my life cuz she's like she gets
her makeup done all the time
Rihanna first of all like just seeing
Rihanna like I've never seen Rihanna for
ten minutes straight do you know any
Mina huh she was just pops up a car but
she just like subtle instagrams like
I've never just spoken to her for ten
minutes
agreed so just getting that was awesome
and she's just so beautiful and like so
interesting looking and like I don't
know she was awesome and I just we're
talking about making her own body
shimmer out of coconut oil back in
Barbados like that was amazing that was
amazing Kylie though like I was laughing
out loud when she said the thing about
Kris Jenner accidentally putting lip
liner eyeliner on her lips and she was
like Courtney I've never seen her laugh
so
I was just laughing and I didn't even
know why yeah exactly they're doing a
better job like you know one ami from
broke I need the less frequent content
but more premium yeah like I don't need
a one video a week with a random model
in a hotel putting on chapstick as
makeup you know totally I'm used to see
like hard core foundation tinted
moisturizer concealer powder baking
bronzer eyebrows like I needed all
agreed and we're getting it we're
getting it anyways Kim should do him Kim
should do one but I feel like I can go
watch Kim's like that's what I felt like
I could go watch that somewhere else but
I never had no and I'm Kylie's app which
I pay for and I'm happy to the video she
puts up of her glamour of other people
doing her glass right which is also very
interesting and random she does snapchat
if we're doing her own makeup but it's
not plenty I'm at high def it's like
kind of choppy like this was great this
was really great I need to get better at
I shadow like I was really good at it
I'm gonna [ __ ] either
like what Kylie does and what people on
Instagram do where they like to comment
like they do like a lid and like a cut
crease I want to go to a class kind of
it's just I should be good at it I'm
gonna have a steady hand I'm good at
everything else I think we just take me
over the top do this looks good I have a
lot of classes I need to go to a coding
class also and I need to go to driver's
ed are you ready for our third story
mm-hmm Elon Musk this is from the New
York Times Elon Musk thinks a mini
submarine could help in the tide cave
rescue okay so this is story we've kind
of been following you on Twitter because
that's how really how it started I've
been following from my news
notifications I'm getting updates that
there are these twelve thai soccer
players and their coach stuck in a cave
and it's absurd Hewitt except understand
how they got stuck hmm but they went on
a bike ride and they went into this cave
and while they were in the cave like it
was flooded with water and it's been I
think ten over ten days something so
crazy
and Elon Musk is coming to the rescue he
came to the rescue
it's there he said yesterday that it was
being shipped in he would arrive in 17
hours so I don't know the exact time but
he was being so great on Twitter
basically explaining what he was making
he made this little diagram basically
there is like there's a very long tunnel
that's very narrow that the boys can
swim out of but it's under water so they
can't hold their breath then there are
the submarine these tiny Navy
seals who have the snorkeling things on
so they can go and they they're getting
to the boys but getting the boys out is
what's hard because it not only isn't
underwater but it takes like 11 hours
it's like a really long drive yeah so
Elon Musk built this submarine that's
narrow enough to fit through the tunnel
that can fit a kid in it so the kid goes
in the submarine and he made like a
pocket for like a radio so we can like
listen to music like so cute and he
tested it in this big pool he rented out
a public school a charter school in LA
and like use the use their pool he
basically simulated they made a replica
of the tunnel and took two scuba divers
and like practice basically what they
would be doing and then built it and
sent it and he's like answering every
person's question on Twitter they're
like well what kind of still are using
you know like people I love with him
this is the whole story engineers from
companies led by Elon Musk the
billionaire known for the outside of the
box ideas like his aspiration to
colonize Mars where n rude to Thailand
on Saturday to offer their expertise to
help rescue 12 boys in their soccer
coach from thum luang cave in northern
thailand the engineers were sent from
Tesla mr. monks electric vehicle company
SpaceX his rocket company and the boring
company which specialises in tunneling
and and construction a boring company
spokesman said there are two or three
engineers on the ground in Thailand with
more on the way the spokesman said he
said representatives from the companies
were in discussions with the Thai
government about how they could help
drivers divers began a rescue mission on
Sunday morning that could continue for
several days said its commander so
update from this story now is they've
got an eighth of the boys out it's taken
so long one Navy SEAL died and like I
saw his picture he was like such a cutie
he was a volunteer he basically like
gave one of the boys like his oxygen and
like drown it was really sad like true
hero and Elon Musk's thing did not get
there in time but they're going to keep
it and use it for future endeavors he
said this was from his Twitter some good
feedback from Keith's experts in
Thailand iterating with them on an
escape pod design that might be safe
enough to try also building an
inflatable tube with airlocks less
likely to work given tricky contours but
great if it does Wow contours are
everything I know well fasten Elon Musk
is everybody know these are tricky
contours I feel like we took a break
from talking about him
and because cuz he was working hard new
true brothers true toasters no are like
obsession with Elon Musk because like
maybe two years ago he was like getting
really popular and like we didn't really
understand what he did for a living cuz
like he made cars book he also was an
astronaut
I don't know and now that I'm like
really well versed and informed on his
business his social life and his mother
I'm obsessed I'm upset his boss and
first well he just said celebrating his
birthday and we did not wish him a happy
birthday which was not cool
that's so unlike us Seibert thank you
Vaughn and I love you so much and this
is just like catapults me back into the
obsession you know what the thing is
with Elon Musk is that like if I saw him
on the street I like wouldn't think that
he's hot but like his brain is hot do
you know any no and so his brain is hot
so automatically he's hot and then you
ain't look at him you're like he said
that he's you know but like just think
like imagine if there was like this
world crisis and like Zack just like
built a submarine like that would never
happen Jewish boys like don't even even
know how to change lightbulbs yeah they
don't know I'm the one hand they don't
know have a chain like to do the
building of the submarine but like they
could do like the engineer get the
planning the strategizing the budgeting
yeah he also tweeted got more great
feedback from Thailand primary path is
basically a tiny kid sized submarine
using the liquid oxygen transfer tube of
Falcon rocket as hull light enough to be
carried by to divert small enough to get
through narrow gaps extremely robust
just like so much and just like this
show um no I really have like nothing
but positive things to say about Elon
Musk even though I read the lines about
him but it's fine I don't I don't like
even if I don't even know what blinds
are talking about but even if they're
all true like he's a great man well one
of the blinds was very interesting he's
like still you know like wrapped up with
Amber Heard okay and she said she's a
beautiful woman
totally she's been through a lot yeah
and one of the blind said that he
invested in a small business of her and
gave her 300 grand
what a great man I could definitely
surround around I feel like Elon Musk's
really like I don't know who puts money
towards things he believes in so maybe
if he saw like one episode of the toast
we could do like the toys from SpaceX
that would be so cool yeah what do you
guys we could do the toast from Mars
down
we should go be the first people like
you know how there are people who are
down to go to Mars and like live there
and be the first like yeah we have no
ties I'm not we could take this show I'm
not down to two
a just travel period being a space I
guess there's no good food in space and
like you can't pee right I'm peeing a
bag like oh I forgot I'm good
I just finished madmen mm-hmm and one of
the episodes in season seven is 1969 we
went to the moon in 1929 to 1968 but
around 1969
now 1968 but the year after and it was
just so crazy like can you think of any
moment in our time where the whole
country maybe even the world is watching
the same thing at the same time I can
think of one thing in recent memory the
wedding the royal wedding uh Caitlyn
well Bruce Jenner's Diane Sawyer special
I felt like the whole [ __ ] I
will never forget that but really like
everyone in the country is watching the
same thing on TV experiencing the same
thing that's just so crazy you know I
absolutely love like worldwide events
that like bring people together and like
everyone's so focused like everywhere
you go everyone's on their phone
watching it like I love [ __ ] like that
and it's like not necessarily celebrity
stuff no no it's just like worldly
cosmopolitan vibes yeah I feel like that
happened so recently and I just can't
remember what it was or even like when
there was that thing with the moon and
everyone had those glasses and everybody
that's standing outside I didn't do it
and I'm like regret that we're shopping
for your wedding dress it was it very oh
my god that was the worst day of my life
I remember I didn't have the appropriate
glasses yeah but that's just like that's
so cool that no matter who you are we're
all so different we're leading very
different lives but we're all doing the
same thing at the same time can I just
say someone just loves to comment I love
that clot is hydrating like I feel like
how unhealthy do people think that I am
I be drinking water deserves applause
you can't even water it's it's social
yeah that's so funny but speaking of
that water speaking of what you just did
oh yeah this next story wildly
interesting and then but here's sec
here's a story from our environmental
department also from your side we need
to find [ __ ] that is not Noble like we
needed news stories newyorktimes.com
Starbucks citing environment is ditching
plastic straws you guys I have so many
thoughts on - cuz you know I'm
guzzling Queen and I live for a straw
for multitude of reasons which I'll get
to but coming from this is news out of
Seattle
Starbucks citing the environment threat
to oceans will ban plastic shards from
all of its stores globally in less than
two years the company becomes a largest
food and beverage company operating
globally to do so Starbucks said Monday
that is making available a stralla slid
at eight eight thousand stores in the US
and Canada for certain drinks Starbucks
Coffee Co estimates the switch will
eliminate more than 1 billion plastic
chars a year the company's announcement
comes a week after its hometown Seattle
band single-use plastic jars and
utensils at businesses that sell food or
drinks in the city
Starbucks said cold beverages in which
straws typically included make up 50% of
the drinks it sells up from just 37
percent five years ago ok use my
thoughts I totally understand like all
it takes is for you to see like one
turtle caught in the straw to realize
that we don't need plastic straws but I
love straw and for someone that wears
lipstick every day and has like crooked
teeth it's really hard to drink
sometimes without either slurping
getting my lipstick on everything or
spilling so I think straws are important
but not plastic straws and I love metal
shots I couldn't agree more
I hate paper straws hate hate and that's
becoming too quick like the quick backup
yeah but it shouldn't eat any restaurant
that wants to get rid of pasta shows I
am here for it but we replace it with a
metal sheet ahh they're reusable no
turtles get harmed in the making of
metal straw and no customers have to get
paper in their mouths no tongue okay so
I especially requested this story
because I is just like a consumer of
restaurants have been noticing in the
past three months like I can't get a
straw anywhere and here's the thing you
know I care deeply about animals and I
really do I care deeply about the
environment an agent that they think
that this is like a good important step
but like I feel like there are so many
other things we could do that would have
just as good of a benefit and not
inconvenience us so much like straws are
necessary what's not necessary is those
like plastic circle things that hold
beer together like let's get rid of
those first yeah and honestly I think
those are even worse for soon those kill
dolphins because it gets trapped in
their mouths like that's okay so why
don't we start with things that we don't
really need like we do not need those
six-pack
hold up yeah we can just get a cardboard
look okay I would literally rather get
rid okay ready this is now imported
straws our straw hold I would
get rid of this before a straw I would
rather get rid of plastic cups plastic
bottles like I think straws are so
important that while it's really great
that the people are now taking notice of
it like I really wish that this would be
like the last thing we got rid of
because like it'll make a difference and
I'm really happy and I don't want to say
that this is a bad thing like I'm being
inconvenienced severely by this whole
thing
if we were to just get rid of like
plastic holders or plastic cups or
plastic bottles like I would feel less
inconvenienced I agree with that
I think Strauss is a really tough place
to start because a lot of people need to
trust ourselves included also when you
drink coffee through a straw you don't
get stained your teeth but when you
don't use a straw you sing your teeth so
then all of a sudden like you need teeth
whitening like also someone commented
that um handicapped people need straws
so if they go to Starbucks like they
still probably still have some probably
have paper straws knowing them no and I
love a metal straw but like a cocktail
but that's just unrealistic like
restaurants restaurants can implement
metal straws Starbucks can't no but like
them being not available at all is
annoying like at certain restaurants
they just don't have them anymore
whereas like if you ask okay you don't
wanna give everyone a straw great but if
I ask for one like I'll pay for it like
straws aren't necessary I just would
like to do like ten other things before
we get rid of straws I agree
like let's stop jumping our trash in the
ocean also if you're let's try polluting
the earth with fireworks like I'm never
getting plastic cups make sure your
dishwasher works in your cups don't
smell because yeah I just can't enchant
with smelly cups and they're happening
worldwide smelly cup syndrome every cup
I drink out of at a restaurant is smelly
that's like my biggest pet peeve I get
so nauseous you can tell when like
[ __ ] washer is dirty or like it hasn't
even been washed
we're like a smelly Fork you can shove
that fork actually take it for me grab
it you can crap it you can exactly I'm
just I love that the world is taking
steps towards environmental soundness
I just wish they would take like five
steps before straws because they're
really necessary I'm being
inconvenienced like and it shouldn't be
hard to want to help the environment you
know like I wouldn't feel any loss if we
were to get rid of plastic beer holders
you know yeah but I feel a loss without
the straw
but maybe you should talk to someone
like
who's the you of who is cheat the way
you are two straws they are two beer I
don't see that's the thing it's not to
be here it's like soda too but like I
think they wouldn't mind if it came in
like a different carrier like a bee yeah
like the way that like uh Stella's come
in right little cardboard carrier like
let's figure out a way to like get rid
of all the shipping boxes or like reuse
them like that's a huge [ __ ] waste I
think people do reuse them whatever I'm
just saying making them biodegradable
I need my straws I'm looking about to
buy up literally all the plastic drawers
in New York cuz I know in a couple days
like they're not gonna be here and I'm
sorry like Seattle making a law against
chars like that's dramatic sorry I agree
okay fifth and final story of a free
before we bring out our special guest
Halsey cries on stage while singing
break up ballad at first concert since
GGC split okay so over the break Jeezy
and Halsey split I was kind of shocked
cuz they go through so much together and
she constantly has his back even though
he has arrested and the two of them like
honestly do drugs and don't care they're
totally on the same they're totally
simpatico so I was really surprised to
hear that they broke up and now I guess
she's upset about it at her concert as
she should because I think they were a
real love story I don't I think she's
like way more talented and like way
above him and he is like trashy to me
and she's like a true artist you know
what I mean I thought he was they are of
equal levels of town I totally disagree
shiness drug use I think everything he
was like he as an artist got a lot of
legitimacy by dating Halsey perhaps but
people like really really love him yeah
I really love her i I really like her
but I think there are people that really
like him we have to look at how many
ends really like he just sings on other
people's songs for sure but now she's
like a true artiste like she writes her
own music or songs are really good I was
listening to one on the radio the other
day and I was like this is a [ __ ]
banger is Halsey that song colors is the
best song ever totally except when you
listen to it really closely it's the
song read by Taylor Swift
oh of course yes lose Windham was blue
but it's literally the same word and
then I googled it to see if anyone had
the same thought and there's a whole
conspiracy oh really
I found myself a home but no I'm just
like I think a she could you better be
like I'm not here to perpetuate GE Z's
career and like make him more famous I
think he's like a bad role model and not
a good singer I agree but do you think
she's a good role model
no but she's a Great Artiste and you can
get away with being like
a shitty person if you call yourself an
artist yeah and like a lot of the great
artists you know struggle struggle I
mean I'm an artist and I struggle with
food addiction so I understand yeah so
tough Slava thank you for speaking on
that he was so very you know I'm gonna
just heal the trauma with Demi Lovato
and her life coach I did but you know
what I'm really like
I followed a meal a lot on its erm I
believe but I don't follow her the
characters in her life like so like I
think either characters in Kylie's life
like I told me you like was tweeting
shada Jordan was good you would know but
I don't know who Demi so burger no me
neither but they're like Demi's stands
do you know and she tweeted good luck on
your blog and I was like who the hell is
this about that is so shady and I just
quickly looked at the replies and
they're like I've almost explaining the
drama so I went to his Instagram he had
basically put up a video that was like
he's a life coach and he was it was like
the video was tell obviously attacking
Demi they obviously a falling out and he
basically was like you can't be like a
[ __ ] you can't be rude you can't be
like inconsistent and and consider it
and then just say it's cuz you're an
artist it was like obviously about damn
yes you can I mean I mean literally just
said that you can and every city had
maybe a hundred thousand comments of all
of Jamie's fans writing good luck on
your blog it was so funny
it was great just leave it this little
shoots video now has a hundred thousand
time now so it's twofold that's how I
feel when I put like haters like when I
blast them on my Instagram story like do
I want to give them the attention do you
block their name out now I do because
that's what they want
yeah I've never done that I've never
posted one or two times like I thought
about it but I was like no one cares
like no wonder no one that's really like
redoing it for me and there are better
ways for me to get my anger out agreed
are you ready for the next segment of
the show just make sure you do all your
housekeeping quickly yeah okay
housekeeping is as follows noon today
become a patreon member and you'll get
access to tickets for my Boston show and
then general public access is on Friday
and when you become a patron member you
get access to actually all of the
episodes that we have recorded so far I
believe and then you'll get our episode
all about the blinds which is this
week's episode we have to do it on
patreon once it's gonna take so long and
to like I just don't like putting like
all these concerns me out for the world
to hear yeah so if we put it behind a
paywall it's like less it's less every
yeah but so next up very exciting we
haven't had Alexis waters on the toast
since we were the breath and it was
probably like the funniest segment ever
she was being so funny oh my god I never
laughed so hard on this and she
literally moved to LA like the next week
I mean like never got her back so I'm
really excited to have her back alexis
is in the building she actually here
with her boyfriend who's so cute and
like you know he's like stoic he's quiet
you know
yeah he's obviously a man of few words
but he's lot going on and said still
softly in kind big stick yes he does so
we're gonna take a quick break and we'll
be joined with Alexis waters in just a
minute so stay tuned and if you have any
questions for Alexis waters feel free to
comment on the Facebook or the YouTube
stream and we will do everything we can
to get them to her
you
Millennials we are back and we are so
excited because we are here without one
of our all-time favorite guests and now
you're a two-timer it's Alexis waters
well in my the first two-timer know
whatever so you had to laugh
you moved yeah and that's your problem
yeah we're gonna get you ready yeah
moving Dallas dead yeah talk about to
the show and he's heard of it he's
definitely parents watching yeah Darren
his assistant co-host sometimes five
years five years so I feel like you used
to be introduced to on like shows and
stuff as bachelor contestant bachelor
paradise connected God now you are a
dolphin which is so are you glad that's
over
okay little this guy came up to me and
up front like a frat boy just screamed
to my face that a bar was like the whole
thing girl go through girl I was like
annoying I mean I did it to myself it
was self-inflicted but now you're
jewelry designer to the Stars I now like
this hoop nation if you guys don't know
Alexis launched a line of hoops and
you're wearing them today and you guys
did it so rude what guys I'm sure but
I'm gonna make yours a break I recently
got them parts I also like I love how
language you guys that my piercings our
minds our line no they're not
symmetrical oh really yeah are they so
happy
well I just have like really sensitive
ears but I'm fine I wore the hoops yeah
I want those ones how you're marrying oh
yeah these are this Alice those are the
good ones yeah they're huge
I love this and I've yeah I'm the bigger
the bigger the bigger the hoe yeah so
what anymore when I saw you know what
like 10 minutes ago the first question I
asked you and I've been wondering ever
since hoop nation came out is how Amy
Schumer got her hands on a pair because
not only did she get a pair of Hoops she
also but then are them on her Instagram
story which was extremely prestigious I
know how because first of all Amy
Schumer love you
second of all she like hit me up while I
was coming bachelor in paradise and was
like oh my god I love you and I was like
oh my god it was asked did you cut
headphone no this is when I was airing
open was airing oh yeah when is airing
and after the peace episode she was like
oh my god I love how you like consoled
is that the word yeah I told Christina
after the whole white teens history huh
and I was like oh my god and I'm like we
yeah I'm here and there like Alamein she
thought oh yeah yeah she sometimes I
checked to see if she seems so I did all
the time I think I don't care I'll like
actually say it and she does I wake up
in the middle of an itemized so that
phony was premiering I feel pretty and
she like asked me to promote I can't
believe did you get a lot of sales from
that yeah yeah much like it's doing wow
yes movement guys so you sold out the
first three styles right yeah and now
how many more do you have right now I
have about like four left what I might
do and then I'm releasing new hoops
tomorrow what island peak yeah they're
like jelly hoops are in right now like a
new site ones you get there bear yes so
I'm like into the jelly hoops so look
out for that today the search other
rings I pretty much they're like tall i
rancher color Oh what color Oh like teal
pink white oh that's really beautiful
Tyler's like I've been picking out hoops
so he's getting into the hoop game too
so Tyler is your boyfriend and he's here
and he's so cute and you're he's all
over your Instagram story I know how did
you guys meet
through Rachel Lindsay had obviously she
like they have like mutual friends
that's so nice yeah they're good well a
lot of questions we got for you were
about Rachel Lindsey's birthday and
that's like the one question I really
want to ask you and you told me buddy
not to hold back so I'm not going to
yeah Rachel Lindsey whom I and her
number one fan I love her more than
anything in this whole world I would
jump in front of a bus for her like I
love her no I remember when she was on
you guys show and she laughs and you
guys continued to talk about her and
she's right there I do you think she
liked that mm Millennials law she's to
Paul
she'd millennial themed birthday party
where like everyone dressed up that's
like yeah me today yeah yeah so she put
up an Instagram story after the birthday
party just like expressing some concern
about some of her friends that like
weren't being cool or something
I don't know I don't really remember and
I know that you know the drama you
pretend like you didn't know backstage
but now I'm gonna make you say it what
was the drama I Rachel Lizzie's birthday
party and who was she directly referring
to oh wait where are you involved yeah I
think I was yeah I was involved okay I
was in trouble oh you were so we die in
Java did you apologize uh no what did
you do we just there was somebody that
was invited that wasn't smooth there no
I don't you guys are not okay right up
non bachelor world he came it was a he
and she got pissed but then it was also
like everybody was like John says you're
like drunken misapplication it wasn't
that serious like workouts the girls
were involved and had to apologize or
didn't about we didn't apologize who
else was it it was me Aston Raven deal
of jasmine yeah and I know you guys are
watching everybody yeah everybody we all
got in trouble but everyone's fine now
yeah we're like sister wives
we like fight like sisters and then we
make up the next day and you're all like
moving to Dallas
yeah Bridget lays there yeah she knows
that say what Raven just moved with
whatever his name is Adam and you're
about to yeah September that's did you
get a house you need a house hunting
house her apartment house so much what I
was looking at ones that like had an
elevator in it and I'm like who's paying
for that one so what is this weekend
your mom is epic she's she was wasted
yes like wasted with my family and
there's babies he was bombed out of her
mind like on the like I wanted a throw
overboard on the boat but come on it's
like an influencer yeah basically she's
very well known me so that like she can
get like coupons and stuff just because
she is that mother of a coupon queen
yeah basically so she goes to store I
got like a discount at this one store
and she like goes there and like if I'm
not with her she's like well Alexa's
they didn't give me the coupon Casey
what are you trying to do here so she's
like a lot of it
hi Brett let's go to show next time yeah
she always says you slide in Sarnia i I
don't try to turn her damn she slide
into mine and I always responded lobby
[ __ ] yeah lights and Amy Schumer it's
Leonard I am a mission yeah
you've had like one of the most
impressive blow ups since the show I did
yes yes and I would be air yeah one of
the questions we got free which was
still funny is like everyone who cuts
their hair short always regrets it do
you regret it now no it looks great and
also it takes me half the times get
ready yeah I love the truth cuz I'm not
I don't really do makeup and hair well
mm-hmm I I watch your videos to get
felt like chopped it he also enjoyed and
it's so hot and so I have like the long
extension so I was like I'm done right
and you don't need extensions anymore
now and well you have one now but don't
tell me one but then I got my a like
something's taken out yes I love
extensions are done they're not going I
was looking at $250 on eyelash
extensions absolutely insane that's
insane
so what I've turned Paradise is like
eyelash extensions yeah yeah but then
you can't go in the ocean I almost
drowned tonight so you guys outside cuz
you better burn oh yes yes you were go
in the ocean I was burning me and Raven
we're like almost died in the ocean cuz
I could not say see ya yeah and then
there was no lifeguard so we always
almost died nobody cared I mean have you
gotten anything else done because you
look amazing do you get fillers no I'm
so brightly and young do I thank you
guys maybe it's the aloe vera that Traci
Waters has been a probably maybe that or
coconut water yeah that's what that's
the Diggle no I'm good I'm just tan and
living my best life you are so glamorous
today and I work out a lot that's yeah
but like it sucks yeah yeah yeah what
are your thoughts on Becca Martinez and
Ravens feud oh yeah no so dramatic oh I
I was away when that happened so I
didn't really like so Braden is
defending Tia because like Rebecca was
being really rude I'm like saying [ __ ]
about - yeah like about how she only
went on the show so she go in Paradise
and get engaged Colton which might be
true but like the show that shows yeah
and literally the whole show is
everybody just like
strategizing yeah and then they like all
bang each other right basically so if we
get a real relationship out of it how
great yeah that's like Raven and them
though
yeah Blake from bachelor in paradise
like yeah actually like really are
obsessed with each other do you think
they're gonna get engaged soon yeah but
maybe to have a pop why was I talking
about teardrop rings Oh like pear shape
I don't know
that's what Rachel Lindsey has yes it I
like that yeah I like this I think
that's the same pair honey yeah they're
gonna get it would mean they're moving
together do you think that they could
get a Neil Lane ring or do they even
want one night I got Adam yeah yeah he
can afford Adam Drake I saw what he did
to his kitchen
real nice as well in my language it's
insane oh you did yeah yeah out of money
to shop Raceway oh yeah
and they watch online and they lunch
curve yeah oh my god yeah yeah I'm gonna
do hoops for young girls like Kardashian
kids
yeah whoo nation little poop nation yeah
a little alley
oh wait I said didn't I say it first no
I 100% at us okay that works
Thanks what else are you up to you're
just living in town so you want to
become a doll's house y-yeah I'll be
moving to Dallas in September yeah so
right now I'm gonna lie but I do it over
one year now right in here what has it
been like I'm not in that way girl
mm-hmm it's hard hard lifestyle of
traffic 24/7 hate it hate it and just
like the people the work all right do
you have LA listeners for three hours
yeah no but you got your podcast is
number one like all over and mostly east
coast but yes yeah because like I
promote it that's true I get for one
percent I heard all the statistics I got
was something that one episode that you
oh really
yeah that's what I had the guy told me
yeah DLO lives in LA and yes I love like
I just I lived with like two of my guy
friends from home and I just always hang
out - yeah yeah but living like what I
heard yeah and when they're stoners and
you're graduating with a real boy yeah
never lived with a boy before
how is it guys oh it's the best it's the
best and everyone who like high get out
the door open no we couldn't be more
different
Wow me and Ben are going up he's in the
shower I'm peeing like it's just it
doesn't matter to see a watt oh he
watches everything he's right there
taking a nap on the on the carpet
they're painted yeah
I'm and the Jackie's opposite like
Jackie literally had sent herself to the
hospital because she never started
eating like I wouldn't poop at his
apartment and I got so sick like
throwing tonight Hospital Nate and then
all they said was like go to the
bathroom you have to go do you still
have the cup of coffee every day yes but
how do you guys not have like a poop
attack when you have like a cup water
coffee
oh yeah cuz when I do Pippa's act
diarrhea yeah yeah like immediately see
him that's what I was thinking
like how does Jackie always like drink
coffee and like still get through the
show you know they drink water I really
feel like I can so like I mean like I
must have like a fast metabolism because
I really should my 500 pounds and I only
weigh like have that that's very true no
I know so like literally out of sit in
the morning like even if it's like a
tiny sip of water diagram do you think
people don't like and listen to us as we
all really talk really you know I was
thinking like 10 seconds ago I was like
no one's gonna understand what we're
talking I know
it's higher I had no idea what we were
talking about yes so you were out there
and when people like you should have
some a little slower
I'm trying yeah like yeah when people
talk [ __ ] about our show like the only
thing they really say it's like they're
illiterate yeah yeah I understand
completely
yeah I love it I hope the generation
pick up for I think that's daughters -
talkers and the morning toast that's
right I think New York like a tri-state
area thing
yes that's true we live out a fast life
highly Politan we live fast die
[Laughter]
so what else would um now that you're in
the relationship you're kind of like
you're never gonna go on power sabacc
ler does he yeah I mean not if I do -
yeah I mean just I mean now that they
can't drink I feel like makes it they
can't drink like everything for that
power - confirmed will cause like when
we went back we were in able to drink
two drinks an hour I mean that's a lot
maybe you're drinking all day from noon
to midnight yeah that's water down its
water Dow so it's even like it's like
one drink an hour yeah from going from
like being able to like open bar I was
there for the open bar yeah you've been
on both sides of the fence yeah and like
the grass is greener the grasses in
greener on the other side I don't like
it I don't think so you're not really
eligible to go back on any of those
shows now whichever do you like a
different whichever duality TV again
Bravo TV Real Housewives over balance
right what do you think they let me onto
seven Jersey accent yeah yeah you do
like be Batgirl
you think so yeah I mean they are gonna
be mean to me they're like who's this
[ __ ] with this yes blackberry Ozzie
they're very territorial
up in here yeah they're very territorial
when it comes to like oh they if you
don't even live in their zip code like
their man and you're like trekking your
ass from the north and I don't like its
Dallas and then what southern part yeah
like she doesn't have a Highland Park oh
yeah yeah I don't think I'm buying how
Soviet Highland Park's you just they
need honestly yeah I think I'll do it
guys watch really story works not the
toast
why we're gonna recap and be your number
one Supporter know the toasters are the
best
yeah that is a toaster I couldn't agree
more they are the best but like if you
ever find a way thing if you ever find a
way to get on real houses italics you're
just gonna have to let me know your
contact because I'm trying to get on
real houses in New York cuz I am a
housewife of New York yeah I don't want
to be fascinating and I just think I'm
at a great level where to show an
amazing
I do think you a Metheny Frankel will
hit it off I just wonder why she can't
be friends with anyone who like wants to
be better than her like I'm fully
accepting the fact that like I'm just as
good as her but not that fit -
regginator know I'm beneath her that's
fine I can accept that no yes now yeah
just as good as her no but like I would
accept a second tier spot just to be
happy is under style love LuAnn be
chosen I would become your best friend
like I would like I would hear from
LuAnn yeah like if when they split up
into separate hotel rooms like I would
be in Laurens room I don't want to be
like her number one yes I am like
wouldn't you know Ramona always needs to
get the room by herself she does get the
first one the best room with a bathtub
yeah I don't sort of it's you know I
think that's all the time and also like
they want us to do yeah right like it's
such an immersive experience yeah
so crazy that people like a very
invested in the bachelor as but I tell
people are invested in bachelors how I
feel about Real Housewives right so does
that make you feel but you're dealt like
people like him know so much about you
and like care yeah oh goodness a my but
that also I'm the same way about Real
Housewives so I got it yeah like you
can't complain but when you go down to
the shore like you go out and about
they're like you're poppin you're like a
local celebs II of the shore yeah but
for like young 21 year olds girls drunk
girls John with girls so I am I like a
good role model you think
it's like you've lived you're so fun and
look at you settling down you're about
to have an elevate and I said yes this
amazing young entrepreneur
is it an entrepreneur it's it's I say
entrepreneur entrepreneur
yeah whatever that's what I am we got a
lot of good questions from Instagram and
we're gonna get to them but I've one
last question before we take from other
people
I saw Korean over the weekend yeah and I
absolutely [ __ ] love her we were
talking about you and she's just like I
love Alexis more than and they she's
like my sister that's what she said oh I
don't know four sisters Oh today it's
only that we're basically sister wives
that's true yeah I just want to know
what your relationship is like with all
the girls from your season what's like
with Nick have you seen him spoken to
with some really dating January Jones I
don't know I'm not quite sure I don't
really keep up okay I keep up okay
living with the Kardashians I keep up
with the Kardashians I don't kept up
with Nick Val's dating way oh but I
still had Michael chawla recently well
whatever comes tell was baby yeah he was
like very depressed and scary really
yeah I really don't like him
I mean I wish him the best I think The
Bachelor show that he's doing is kind of
funny
what was this like I said I don't watch
the episodes and then I have to do
recaps I mean just watching it Klaus so
thanks to Nick dial for like recapping
it for you yeah we're capping it for
bean and Christina back together mmm I
don't think so
someone saw them at a hotel like having
breakfast in the morning like after a
night together yeah more than I did well
because the tasters are everywhere and
they take pictures of everything oh
really
yeah oh yeah are you in the toaster
States the group no not I'm gonna be as
you don't know do you know I just sent
out baby Ana's in the group she just
joined they just so Bibiana comment on I
think what up there bianna yeah baby
yeah we get along yeah no I haven't but
like we should party together yeah
absolutely
paradise right I can't I honestly can't
wait for paradise I think it's paradise
is the best show on TV it really is but
about using almost the worst but it's
about that it gives us people from a
parent but you can't afford that the
other yeah you
and he like tea from paradise like any
couples I'm sure there's an engagement I
don't know if there's any engagements
but I like know some tey it does it
sound like it's shaping up to be a good
season
yeah - what I shared the tear now I mean
it's not really good tea to spell like I
feel like you guys can wait for the tip
okay fine you know and this is a no
spoiler zone anyway yeah oh it is okay
good
what do you think about Taylor and Derek
splitting up did you see it coming
no I liked both of them so it's like but
I I'm really close with Derek so I like
talked to Xander - I texted him I was
like how are you doing and he just said
like he sent me at pictures of liquor
stores nearby
he's hot yeah they sued yet and he's
never watches the show so I heard about
it everyday I could tell everyone that
literally last night I had sex with
Derek and I could show pictures I could
show the video sexy and then we'll know
he never [ __ ] watch as a show it's so
rude
then what where's that benefit huh never
ever he literally he has probably since
this new show he's probably watched like
maybe one episode for five minutes and
when he does he's like talks about it
for a month because he wants him to
think that was so funny when I was like
six episodes ago I love watching Ben
like it all your SAP talks so much it's
amazing with the golf club obviously no
idea I was gonna gonna him visitor on
Ben is like practicing his swing in the
backyard like a monkey
Tyler was a perfect lake was about to be
a professional golfer way yeah but it's
like serious that's like yeah it's a
quiet sport yeah I probably couldn't
have married you
yeah I get even on top golf you're not
really allowed to talk really but not
top golf like the regular wine like not
top golf the one when you just like all
hate you're the one to talk yeah the
range you're not allowed to talk yeah my
sister why we were like cheering and
like the old people were like looking at
lately I thought it's like a it with
like drinks no top golf is now I think
that's why they made top dog Oh
interesting golf was talking terribly
she enjoyed that one I know
he's like really serious about it it's
really annoying like they take all day
and we're come back do you think that
this is how things are funny yes yeah we
got a lot of questions not questions
just like comments on people really
enjoying your stories we will adjust for
right now because I said you have a
quarter-sized bellybutton and I wanted
to put that with you yeah he said Noah
losses we can't do that honestly here at
the toast we think a big belly button is
a symbol of strength it's a power it's a
power without you guys how I'm not
because he was like very offended he
said don't put anything about my belly
by actually facing it yeah Harry yeah he
actually he's very clean like yeah but
like takes longer than I do to get ready
like he's very good
he loves his mama yeah no I can lick a
quarter sized belly button that's big
yeah but no could you get a quarter I
just tried but it's only time Oh
dime in there so I think it's a where
did you get the dime oh I'm in my bag
yeah but I said open a quarter sized
belly button sounds funnier it does and
it's probably human you said I'm not
allowed to lie is he watching right now
no okay that's good it's like betting
he'll literally yeah yeah I didn't
support my lips at all but he does not
wait you said Taylor mocha and what's
the same broke up I had another breakup
I wanted you to comment on um but that's
something else because I okay fewer
questions who from the friend tried from
the franchise would be your bridesmaid
if you were to get married to Tyler who
could show well I'm ever I mean all the
girls from my crew but then I have like
paba
you guys my braid and your sister my
sister Nikki watches hope that she's
watching she's text me right before I
went on and was like hey Nikki well hey
Nikki she's like okay watching waiting
for you and it gave me anxiety attack
but I'm probably
Astrid because Astrid was dating Tyler's
friends yes so are they still together
no ashes on parenting right and that was
weird
did you break up - um paradise and I get
back together with him or they're not
together no they're not together so
she's a really just broke up what
happened don't tell me yeah no spoilers
I saw one in the kitchen so it's not
swarek's I didn't seek it out Ravan
amyloidosis
- yep or do jazzman but I don't know the
progress Oh big rage yeah do you think
he would be a bridesmaid for big rich I
tried like I told people that I was but
I don't think I am he put it out in the
universe
it'll of Attraction yeah like I went to
her engagement party with a bridesmaid's
dress on it's so funny and everybody's
asking me if I was bridesmaids and I
said yes but yeah he was not confirmed
ask believe receive yeah she wedding
planning yet yeah they're probably gonna
do like a destination wedding not that
not I would know cuz I'm the bride's me
I don't so it's the opposite Ellen eyes
my name no they're not but they've been
offered it for sure right yeah for sure
she's a lawyer yeah I have a very
important question Bona thoughts on
scalloped fingers do you guys watch the
proposal well no I broke one last week
on the show on Tuesday so pretty and
cute oh really she won they were engaged
for two weeks
oh they actually were yeah and then she
was like but how do you not how do you
get proposed to somebody and but not
have sex and not all they're laughing
and they got for two weeks and I was
like so in the two weeks I felt like did
you have sex she said no I'm mind blown
it is mine it's fake okay I've never got
the ring cuz he was supposed to wait
until after the Arab so dared so she
wouldn't be like spotted with it and
they broke up before the episode even
aired so she never even got the ring she
wore for like ten seconds on the show
that is literally say but no I have not
watched the proposal but I hope I wish
the best for scallops yeah Chris said I
really can't believe I started that
she's really nice too girl the entire
way yeah we went to dinner with her
national she was lovely did she eat
scallops
no but she did eat a lot I can't look at
this and not think of it yet I've
literally told the story once I've asked
my partner and they exaggerated it was
out of my hands at that point that's and
then people were like glasses here's
told me in and I'm calling you a bully
yeah but I was like bro if somebody hit
you with scouts you would be pissed off
too
like Scouts don't smell like bluntly
dish yeah so imagine smelling your
shoulder every five seconds it's not
like [ __ ] history it really it was
like a real story that happened but it
was and we were in a crowded car yeah
imagine being squished ball its scalp
shoulders it wasn't a good time
I just wasn't wiping and they just like
took it to a whole nother level that's
classic never yeah but I would never
like be mean to somebody no totally but
like that must be so embarrassing for
you started she's really embraced it
though they yeah they mentioned a
proposal to and she really does like top
so I was like maybe like she should
start like a food seafood line yeah yeah
[Laughter]
okay one final question for you because
we're way over time yeah oh look I only
wear hoops yeah me too so it was like
night oh that's the biggest I ever oh
really
do you wear small medium or large huge
oh really I wear ones that I hang on my
shoulders so why did I sending you the
big pair I don't know I got small ones
I'm like oh these are cute but like I
was like okay yeah sending you those
ones off your ears I don't know why I
thought you were a medium type gap no
I'm totally like bigger and now that I
have a new neck and I can wear my hair
up hair up with hoops is so cute yeah no
that's all I wear so it's like I'm like
now I literally only shop for hoops yeah
and I only have there's only one place
for like I have there's no like you
wants to go to hmm for everybody right
this is just all hoops all times like oh
and they're all different size
combination is a great no discrimination
in my in your in your brand in my brand
cupellation this is the greatness it has
on black white or like every big nation
pink jelly how did you come up with hoop
nation name I just always like hashtag
hoop nation like it's written but then
like I had to like buy the foundation
trademarks this yeah and it's like a new
woman since the last time you guys saw
me I know you're still official with
your trademark I know I can't wait and
then like little nations coming soon
yeah guys follow if you care little of
nation but they're great quality yes
they aren't cheap price and the little
box was so cute with you little picture
and oh my
or you like I say have it like it's a
you weren't happy and it took me a few
days to turn it over and then I saw it
and I was like that's so sweet and the
picture is exploding around my apartment
like yeah yeah I throw it out so I just
got it so cute it is right it's just
like happy like and it wasn't ripped
like everyone got it we got it cuz were
special but ever answer yeah I had an
awkward moment like the other day
because someone was like oh I got a note
- does your say the same thing and I was
like I'll just don't know if you guys
want to know more talking about check
out hoop nation my Alexis
yes it's Alexis amazing line of boobs
but also just follow Alexis waters 13
okay no 13 and Alexis voters underscore
oh it was a 13 I'm gonna wait b-24 time
brosman number okay what anymore
oh you want to do the show my bed Mose
Claudia oh yeah one day show tomorrow I
might not want to just show Friday
because you want to go out I'm having a
party you remember day last year yeah
and here uh people best thing I know
I've known a good friend here the best
like literally my birthday was made I
stopped a 4-h I was like I was obsessed
with her but we didn't know her yet and
she can show us the Bachelorette that
was like a bit like the first episode
was airy and she's she's like a historic
figure as the first black but she's so
epic and she and she's now she's doing
is PN
oh yeah she's just like no and you
buttered my birthday like I've never
felt cool everybody's watching party
right like I let you make this - yeah
like there was people at the bar you
literally shoved I'm sorry right coming
through
yeah and big raised a drink first and
then I got a ticket oh yeah yeah I think
that could make you watch this so add
Alexis waters underscore keep up with
Alexis who nation and Tyler and his mom
and this is the morning toast we'll be
back tomorrow
we'll see you that and peace
you